breaking news tonight canada banned some
passenger flights to keep covid 19 from
spreading
what countries are affected and what
difference will it make to the rise of
the variants
plus the halifax region is now just
hours away from entering a near total
lockdown
ontario's premier apologizes i know we
made a mistake
his new pledge for paid sick leave as
his political popularity plummets
ambitious new targets from canada and
the u.s to cut carbon emissions and we
will continually strengthen our plan
the new goals and the skepticism and
when trash becomes treasure my hope is
that
i make five to ten thousand in a month
fashioning a booming business from
selling second-hand clothes
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news new travel
restrictions just announced by the
federal government
direct flights into canada from india
and pakistan will be banned for
30 days starting tonight india has had
an explosion of covet 19
cases it hit a global record today more
than 314 thousand new infections
in just one day the surge is being
fueled by a new variant first detected
in india
given the epidemiological situation in
india
it makes sense to pause travel from that
region while
our scientists and researchers have an
ability to better understand this
variant of interest to better understand
uh where the trajectory of of the cases
in that region is going
abigail beeman is following this abigail
why is the federal government doing this
now well donna there has been
mounting pressure on the government to
do this that variant
dubbed a double mutant has already been
found
here in canada the ban involves
passenger
flights and commercial flights from
india and pakistan
for the next 30 days although cargo
flights carrying
vaccines among other things will not be
impacted the federal opposition had been
calling for specifically
this while the premiers of ontario and
quebec wrote a joint letter calling on
the prime minister to cut international
flights
and to step up restrictions at land
crossings
i'm expected on the u.s side i just drop
off all my
commercial goods that i'm dropping off
and i'm expected to come straight home
i can't i can't even get gas there todd
wrigglesworth crosses the ontario new
york state border daily and is exempt
from
quarantine he says this small crossing
is getting busier
i usually see the same cars over and
over again but i'm seeing a lot i don't
recognize so i think it's either people
coming back from florida
the canada border services agency
doesn't track why people cross but it's
no secret people have been trying to
avoid the mandatory hotel quarantine by
using a land border instead
for those arriving by air the public
health agency of canada says at least
144 people in bc
and 211 in ontario face a 3 thousand
dollar fine
for refusing to go to a
government-approved quarantine hotel
since march 2020 there have been at
least 801 total tickets issued for not
complying with the quarantine act
since hotel stays became mandatory the
public health agency of canada said it
got
nearly 275 thousand day one test results
back from both air
and land travelers and 3732 people
tested positive
that's 1.4 percent or more than one in
every 100 people
thursday's decision to ban flights from
india and pakistan was based on a
breakdown of those positive cases
while india accounts for 20 percent of
recent air travel volumes to canada
over 50 percent of all positive tests
conducted at the border are from this
country and a similarly high level of
cases compared to travel rates have also
been linked to pakistan
is it too late i don't think it's ever
too late but on the other hand too you
know once they get a foothold and
they're being transmitted
they they certainly can uh can get
amplified
and there are still some unanswered
questions the public health agency of
canada
wouldn't tell us how many of those
people who tested positive were
isolating nor how many people refused to
take a test
at all donna all right abigail beamon in
ottawa thank you
now to ontario premier doug ford who had
been front and center throughout the
pandemic
held his first news conference in nearly
a week today
he's self-isolating because one of his
staff has tested positive for covet 19
so
he appeared via video link from his late
mother's home
he said it is not lost on him that he is
still getting paid
while isolating and he apologized for
closing playgrounds and trying to give
police arbitrary powers policies
he swiftly reversed after a public
backlash
i know we got it wrong i know we made a
mistake
and for that i'm sorry and i sincerely
apologize
ford is now promising a provincial sick
pay program but there's no detail on
what it will be or when it will
happen meanwhile hospitals in ontario
are still overloaded there are 2 350
ontarians in hospital with covid19 now
806 of them are in icu
588 are on ventilators global's queen's
park bureau chief
travis danraj is with me from toronto
travis
premier ford has been criticized for
hesitating to act and then
going too far and for not listening to
his own science advisors
what are you hearing about his strategy
and what's going on behind the scenes
well i'm hearing that there's a lot of
chaos behind the scenes to be quite
frank donna you know
we saw over the weekend that as you
mentioned
they reversed decisions pretty quickly
within 24 hours on playgrounds and some
policing powers
and i've heard that at the cabinet table
there was a lot of pushback to those
decisions
and the premier's office ultimately came
down and some of these advisers
including his chief of staff
from what i'm hearing decided that they
were going to go with this decision on
playgrounds
it is not something that any expert that
i know of has asked for
and and that is one of the real
criticisms here that the premier
continues and his government continues
to
disregard some of the expert advice that
they are hearing
and there's a question as to whether or
not and how much
politics are playing a part in some of
these decisions so travis what now for
premier ford does the
fact he's committing to paid sick days
for essential workers
perhaps tell you he might be prepared to
listen more
i think today's news conference does
signal a shift and i think you you saw
that with
the tone that the premiere had coming
out it is not often that we hear from
this premiere
a flat out apology and admission that he
was wrong that the decision that his
government made was wrong
usually he digs in his heels and he
sticks to his gun so to speak
we do know that there will be some sort
of paid sick day program
what that looks like right now is still
unclear
but the experts have been calling for
that for some time they've also been
calling for
essential workers to be vaccinated so on
those two fronts i think that you will
definitely see
a shift and the premier knows that this
is a political calculation for him as
well
because his approval ratings right now
are going down
in recent polls they've sunk about 20
points or so so i think we will start to
see some changes when it comes to the
government strategy
okay travis don raj in toronto thanks
tough new restrictions are coming to
parts of nova scotia
after a rise in new coven cases reported
today
there are 38 new infections detected in
nova scotia that's the biggest single
day jump in nearly a year
community spread is happening in the
halifax area so starting tomorrow the
region will go into a four week near
total
lockdown these restrictions are meant to
be a circuit breaker
they are designed to curb social
activity so that we can protect our
health care system from surges and keep
our vaccine rollout on track
as part of the new restrictions
restaurants in the halifax area will be
takeout only
in-person sports and social events are
banned and people are being told to
avoid all
non-essential travel turning now to a
rare meeting of minds at a difficult
time for the world and bold new pledges
for action on climate change u.s
president joe biden hosted a virtual
summit of dozens of world leaders today
including china
india russia the uk germany and canada
and he committed to cutting us
greenhouse gas emissions
by as much as 52 percent by the end of
this decade
this is the decisive decade this is the
decade we must make decisions
that will avoid the worst consequences
of a climate crisis
this is a moral imperative an economic
imperative
a moment of peril but also a moment of
extraordinary possibilities
it is a pledge that will require fast
and far-reaching changes from how people
power their homes to the cars they drive
and the jobs
they do canada which has yet to meet
previous climate targets pledged today
even more ambitious ones our chief
political correspondent david aiken
looks at the promises
and the reaction u.s
president joe biden made the call to
climate action
and canada's prime minister responded
our new climate target for 2030
is to reduce our 2005 emission levels
by 40 to 45 percent
the previous target was to cut emissions
by 30 percent
and to do that by the end of this decade
canada is now
on track to blow past our old target
of 30 reduction below 2005 levels
but some critics say canadian
governments have a history of setting
targets
but never hitting them others say the
targets are not ambitious enough
in any event many experts say hitting
the new targets
is possible and i think it's going to be
tough it is ambitious
but it will require a radical overhaul
of western canada's energy sector
it's going to be a transition everybody
recognizes that and and we need to get
to the point where we're not combusting
carbon that's what net zero means you've
got to get to a point where you're not
combusting carbon as a source of energy
but wilkinson conceded that his
government has yet to come up with the
detailed plan
to meet the new targets trudeau
announced at the summit
we will need to continue to do work over
the coming nine years
which remain between now and 2030 there
certainly are areas where we believe
that we can continue to accelerate
progress
some potential ideas a massive home
retrofit program to plug
energy leaks a complete change to
canada's transportation
supply chain and the creation of new
kinds of
energy industries the two natural
resource
wild cards would be hydrogen and
biofuels second generation biofuels
um you know is there potential for
exports from canada
but all agree whatever plan the
government tables to meet its new
ambition
to quickly cut emissions it will cost
billions
david aiken global news ottawa
canada's greenhouse gas emissions
represent only about 1.6 percent of the
global picture
and president biden who said america
represents about 15 percent of the
world's emissions
made the case that no nation can solve
this crisis on their own
the other big emitters china and india
both heavily dependent on coal
did not commit to new targets today but
as jackson proskow reports their hands
may be forced by the economic realities
of climate change
and an emerging demand for green
products
outside the white house activists
dropped a pile of manure to signal their
dissatisfaction with the new u.s
emissions targets
not ambitious enough they say the united
states isn't waiting
we are resolving to take action inside
president joe biden found a virtual
audience thrilled by america's return
there can be no doubt about the world
needing
your contribution if we really want to
fulfill our ambitious goal
four years ago there was global dismay
after president donald trump withdrew
from the paris accord
entering into an agreement that
disadvantages
the united states today experts believe
biden's climate goals are well insulated
from future shifts in the political
winds
our companies our citizens our states
our cities
are moving forward making making the
opponents increasingly
kind of the anomaly in part because
money talks
u.s climate goals are now wrapped up in
the global race to own the green economy
there are opportunities here economic
opportunities here for whoever takes
climate change
and its solutions the most seriously
that sets up potential cooperation and
competition between the u.s and china
the world's manufacturing powerhouse and
largest greenhouse gas emitter
china has so far shied away from
near-term emissions targets
but says it aims to be carbon neutral by
2060
10 years after biden's goal for the u.s
what tethers us together
with chinese energy transition and
emissions reductions is the fact that
they're basically servicing
our appetite for emissions biden's bet
seems to be there will be no alternative
but for china and the rest of the world
to act far
sooner because the costs of not would
simply be
too high jackson proskow global news
washington coming up how canada's goal
to be greener will affect people who
work in oil and gas
scientists have long been warning the
world is running out of time to stave
off the catastrophic
impact of climate change the federal
government has made the most ambitious
pledge yet to curb greenhouse gas
emissions but
it won't be easy in 2019 canada's top
emitters were alberta
ontario quebec saskatchewan and bc with
alberta leading the way
by far together they released 91 percent
of canada's total greenhouse gas
emissions
the oil and gas sector was the largest
source accounting for 26 percent of the
total
an increase of 87 percent from 1990 to
2019
the hike is mostly attributable to the
increased production of crude oil
and the expansion of the oil sands
industry
that is largely why canada is the only
g7 country whose greenhouse gas
emissions have increased
since the paris agreement the oil and
gas industry is a big emitter but also a
huge
economic driver in canada and as eric
sorensen reports that makes shifting to
a green economy
a big challenge in the capital of
canada's biggest oil producing province
one more home is going solar a symbol of
an alternative energy future
alex mialovich used to work in oil and
gas but saw an opportunity seven months
ago to pivot
to installing solar panels it's been
pretty uh
non-stop busy lately we've got two or
three jobs going a week with my crew
so it's been actually really good the
company he works for kuby renewable
energy
is already changing the face of edmonton
it installed solar cells on almost
700 windows to power a portion of the
city's convention center
it's super satisfying turning on a
system and seeing all that power being
generated just by the sun
but the transition will be disruptive
for an industry as massive as alberta's
oil and gas
sector in fort mcmurray there is no
imminent green economy to rescue a
community that depends enormously on the
nearby oil sands
and has seen jobs lost to a pandemic on
top of the oil slump
it's just taken an immense toll on the
psyche of the city
in terms of the optimism that we used to
feel in canada a shift away from oil and
gas will not be felt evenly
alberta saskatchewan and newfoundland
and labrador account for most oil sector
jobs
specifically oil and gas extraction
represents 1.5 percent of the national
labor force
but in communities like fort mcmurray
and cold lake it's 25 to 30 percent
having gainful employment is immensely
uh huge for them they they need this
work ottawa sees the job crunch coming
proposing 250 million dollars over three
years
to upskill and redeploy workers in
growing industries
and 55 million to support in part a just
transition for workers in sectors like
energy we're now starting to see more
of a proactive role by the federal
government to make direct investments
in the clean energy transition that we
ought to focus those in the communities
that are going to bear that brunt of the
impact the uncertainty in the oil patch
is real
but so are the small examples where
workers are being retrained
a lot of the skills that i've developed
over the years in oil and gas
you know i can bring them over to
renewables and still use that kind of
stuff
alex mielovich says there's room for
more workers to retrain as he has
for a job that looks like it'll be
around for a while
eric sorensen global news toronto
another funeral for a black man killed
by the police
still ahead remembering dante wright
family and friends gathered in
minneapolis today to honor the life of
dante wright
the 20 year old unarmed black man was
shot and killed by a white police
officer during a traffic stop wright's
mother spoke to her son just moments
before that deadly encounter
today she and his father were overcome
with emotion
when he walked in the room he lit up the
room he was a
brother a jokester
he was loved by so many he's gonna be so
missed
take your time katie words can't even
explain how
i feel right now you know
that was my son
wright was remembered as an adoring
father to his one-year-old son who bears
his name
hundreds came to the minneapolis church
for the funeral including
families of other black men killed in
police custody and at one point members
of george
floyd's family were called to the front
showing solidarity
with the grieving family cashing in on
hand-me-downs next the sustainable
shopping boom
nasa's perseverance rover just made
oxygen on mars
it's a giant leap that may one day turn
science fiction into fact
allowing humans to survive on the red
planet perseverance used an instrument
called moxie to convert carbon dioxide
into breathable air
after an hour moxie produced about 5.4
grams of oxygen that's enough to keep an
astronaut alive and healthy
for about 10 minutes of normal activity
since the pandemic began much of the
fashion industry has taken a hit
but not the resale sector the online
market for used clothes is growing
faster than the market for new ones
as robin gill reports a younger
generation is reassessing both its
social values
and the bottom line laurel grad has a
side
hustle i'm a professional shopper in a
way a nurse by day
and a thrift seeker at night i think
it's slowly turning into a career
i didn't know i would have the 31 year
old spends her free time perusing thrift
stores
looking for deals on trendy clothes and
then reselling them
online she's made some serious cash on
sites like facebook marketplace
and apps like poshmark in our first year
of operations here in canada we
have had 1.4 million active users so
that's definitely shows
the the hunger and the appetite for the
resale market poshmark launched in 2019
but there are
similar apps that are pushing the used
economy
within the next 10 years what we're
going to see is
the global market for these second-hand
purchases is going to go up to
they're seeing 80 billion dollars
worldwide consumer trends show a younger
generation wants to be more socially
conscious
while saving consumers want to be more
ecologically conscious
obviously if you buy second hand you're
using resources that exist rather than
purchasing new stuff
you're choosing to wanting to extend the
item
the life of the item thrift stores have
been around for generations
they rely on canadians to clean out
their closets and donate the items
many thrift stores help fund outreach
programs for low-income families
so are the thrift seekers robbing them
of their bottom line
that was the dilemma facing laurel grad
until she did some research
they need us to buy it so 99
of their income comes from buyers and so
they want people to come in buy the
clothes and then that can go back into
the community her conscience clear
she's now thinking about giving up
nursing her business on the side
is growing my hope is that i make five
to ten thousand in a
month from selling second-hand clothing
what started out as a hobby to make a
little extra cash
just may be a full-time job after all
robin gill global news
vancouver and that is global national
for this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's here in canada is the hamlet
of delau
southwest of brandon manitoba thanks for
watching robin gill will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and i will see you
again on saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]